[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
time
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sleep
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
chesty testing
testing
can you guys hear me
am i being heard
let me look let me look let me double
check
that you guys can hear me let me double
check
you should be able to hear me
but sometimes things don't work out the
way it should
sometimes
you just can't hear people and you gotta
double check and make sure everything's
going good
hold on let me readjust my mic
seems like a pretty good place for my
mic right here
let me see if putting this over here is
going to affect that
let me see let me see
i have started the show nine lives okay
damn give a give a dude a second to to
adjust
man you guys are feeding man i respect
it though i respect it
so we got a uh someone joined the realm
uh lord may ho who for
i definitely if i butchered your name
and i apologize welcome to
the realm definitely put the put those
logos in the chat man welcome him to the
realm uh we appreciate you know enjoy
the stay man enjoy the stay get some
guess i don't know get the little the
chicken on the bones man get the chicken
on the bones i don't know what people
ate back then but we're gonna we're
gonna assume it's some chicken on a bone
uh are you good hustle
okay okay well hustle is
okay
look
i tried i tried something fly it did not
work sorry y'all it is it is perfectly
fine also we get it we understand
all right got stuff you had to do man
you got stuff you had to do
so we got a good show for you guys uh we
do have
we are going to talk about the halo
infinite story revi uh reviews
i have played the game so i have to be
very
i am open to talk about a lot more than
i was a couple days ago
but there are certain things i still
can't talk about for like story purposes
if that makes sense also does that make
sense
yeah because i our job is going to grill
you but i guess we'll we want to you can
groom me it's just if i can't answer it
i'm gonna just say yeah
i want to be fair to the audience
because i do have i have quite a few
questions actually yeah we will
definitely get to that um we also are
going to be talking about
playstation game pass aka spartacus
we're going to talk about that get that
we're going to break that down and and
it looks like you know it's not official
it's not been confirmed there's just
been some leaks sprinkled around the
internet that it's possible xbox one
npd's for november
so
i want to talk about that actually it's
a little bit worse than npd's also uh
there wasn't a lot of characters to work
with it's possible microsoft won
worldwide numbers in november
but
uh no no we'll talk about it
because the screenshot i saw
and it looked legit but we don't know
until we see the actual screenshots from
from the actual people it showed
microsoft winning in the united states
by like like over a hundred thousand
units
uh and uh that was able to carry over to
uh the rest of the numbers but like i
said that particular thing
that's nothing
but speculation i don't want no one
going to twitter saying addict said this
addict doesn't say nothing
addict is
just going off what everyone else goes
off
so all right that's that's the topic for
you know we might sprinkle little topics
here and there because there's a couple
things that's going on you know and
hustle uh he might got some stuff he
wants to talk about so i appreciate
everyone coming through this the attic
show where we speak about the the past
president future of gaming i got my
co-host with me hustle and motivate how
you doing hustle
i'm doing well i'm doing well had uh
you know just some adult stuff to take
care of i'm happy to say that i
resolved that resolution and i'm back
i'm here uh we haven't been here in
how long has it been now it's been a
couple weeks since we've been here just
i've got stuff going on i've always had
the mindset that it's like
if there isn't nothing to talk about
let's not waste our time the other
the the audience's time sure me and you
together we could probably make anything
sound fun but if i'm not feeling it i
ain't gonna come and do it if that makes
sense so no i i one thousand percent
appreciate that because nothing was
going on up until recently and i was
like good we don't want to well we don't
really gotta get it on like that um and
we do the game the game day stuff i
almost said game night but we do game
day stuff we play halo with the people
and you know hopefully it'll be gears
when that time rolls around with the
people i know you don't like gears too
much attic but you know hopefully we'll
be able to throw some more multiplayer
stuff with the with our people in yeah i
will play
gears
because everyone's been trying out games
for me but i'm not i'm a [ __ ] the whole
time would be real with you i'm a [ __ ]
the whole time
ah
so all right
let's let's jump straight into it also
let's jump straight into it
um
let's talk about these xbox potentially
winning
hardware npd's and when i say
potentially it looks like they might
have actually won worldwide numbers now
this is true and the reason i'm i'm
saying potentially because i ain't going
out there scouring the internet looking
for enough screenshots if you guys want
that you can look for it we just talk in
the speculation moment that
maybe they did win it and what of our
opinions on what attributed to that win
so hustle first off
if this is
the case and they did win worldwide for
november keep in mind it's just november
it's not every month they ain't winning
overall it's looking like it's just
november would that surprise you
would it surprise me not really
considering um game pass probably sold
those xboxes in the first place
second of all it's easier to find that
xbox series s than it is a ps5 digital
or a physical edition and the xbox
series that's those those are the
easiest ones to find um
and they just had like a marquee title
come out in november which we didn't
really know
we didn't really know like what was
gonna happen with um forza and with halo
dropping halo did a surprise drop so
like that really could have helped at
all so
so would it be surprising no it wouldn't
be surprising i think
for them to get this one when it
wouldn't be but you said it went
everywhere and i kind of i do want to
see those screenshots now i do want to
see them because i want to see you know
what it's hitting for because i have not
seen them but
that's that's wild
let me see if i can find them because i
sent it to a chat
now let me okay if i can find this
screenshot itself okay here it is all
right and while you're looking for that
i did want to like further this point
like what that tells me is it's not that
necessarily xbox is more popular in
playstation that tells me that you
really couldn't find a playstation
anywhere like at all that means they're
probably not being produced in high
numbers if that is the case because
we've seen either either nintendo
or we've ever seen playstation just
a month i'll say yeah after yeah month
after month
year after year like pretty much don't
they don't give xbox no no shine no burn
in that regard so if that is the case
i mean well look i feel that i feel it
but that means you probably couldn't
find a playstation or
even if you could find one because you
know the skype was to buy those up
anyway so even if you could find one
that means the scalpers got them and
they probably didn't produce them at a
high enough rate that's my only like
logical thinking behind it
yeah
i see where you're coming from that a
little bit i guess like to me
it's all about what exactly is
being
like the conditions uh so uh let me go
ahead and bring up this i'll probably
just go ahead and do a
a
i'll show the actual
let me get it
because i i think people need to see it
so
how it goes is right now i'm looking at
it now it's looking like
this was something that was
shown
it is not letting me delete that for
some reason let me just make another one
all right
okay i'm not going to sit here for 20
minutes trying to figure that out all
right there we go that's so good right
so here's
here's what was shown
uh i will send you the link actually
hustle
i'm gonna put it in the chat how about
that i'm gonna put it in the chat
all right cool i got the chat right up
right up above our system matter of fact
uh hold up i got it i got to actually
copy i never intended on doing this but
you said that you know we might as well
go over it so
here's what we're looking at now
so let me go back into it all right so
this is this is what we're seeing this
is the chat
so
this we don't know if this is true or
not
i want to point that out there
this is complete speculation
but the mpd's it looked like it was not
598 7706
to
ps5 431 1138
uh it does look like you know in the
other parts of the world
playstation definitely destroyed my uh
microsoft i mean i wouldn't just say
destroyed uh you know it doesn't look
like it was too bad across seas it's
like a you know
maybe a little less than a hundred
thousand so it looks like you know in
the united states they had a decent lead
that was able to
leverage with the rest of the world you
know what i'm saying and it does look
like overall
they beat them by like 60 000 the xbox
series x and s
so
what what do you think of this
i mean if we're going for complete
accuracy i mean this is accurate enough
the way the xbox doesn't sell in japan
so if i had to go off of this i wouldn't
say that this was fabricated i would i
would like to think that this isn't
fabulous fabricated um addict you have
to correct me
is the second flag
is that
europe i don't know tell pete people
people in the chat tell me what that
represents is that the uk
is that just like
a bunch of continents together and they
consider that like the you know i don't
know what that means
but uh i do know that the third one is
japan
no you know that i don't know and
microsoft is absolutely getting
destroyed in japan but you know what's
crazy i look yeah sony ain't doing that
hot in japan either
so that was my next question that was my
follow-up because i i don't follow mpd's
at all i was going to ask you how how
were they doing in japan because that
num under 10 000 does seem low to me
that only doesn't seem low to me it's
kind of like abysmal that's kind of
pathetic to be honest with you um
like i you were the thought that's
playstation all the all the other stuff
goes to playstation that isn't on
microsoft so like rpgs jrpgs and stuff
like that all that stuff is typically on
playstation or switch so but if if these
numbers are true
don't mess sony is going to pick it up
in japan because that's that to me looks
wild
as long as i've been following this
stuff until like 2013 that to me is
that that's surprising that's very
surprising i would i would never know i
think
i think the issue we're seeing here
hustle
is i think some of the japan audience is
kind of loki gave a hope of hope when it
comes to playstation
and you know if you look at like certain
things like they've been shutting down
uh japanese orientated studios
so i think you're seeing you know maybe
like a little bit of revolt off that
audience
yeah if you look at like their biggest
selling franchises what are they hustle
what what's playstation's biggest
selling franchises they're western
marketed games
uncharted
you know
horizon zero dawn so i think that you
know i don't know i'm not clearly i
don't know 100 of what goes on in that
market but to me what it's looking like
is the japan market the japan consumer
base in general might be
you know not necessarily boycotting
playstation but they're like why should
we invest into something that's clearly
not investing into us anymore
um
and that's right
and plus
uh they're a lot they do like the switch
phones so there is a lot of you know
things go that go into that but it's
still interesting to know that
playstation isn't selling the greatest
there anymore
um i mean and you know and it must be
true as far as what japan goes if we are
to believe these numbers
i mean they
their lifestyle is
i mean compact i guess that's the best
way for me to put it for as far as their
apartments how they game how they game
on the train how they catch public
transportation then just setting the
third
so i don't know man it's that um
hmm and you said they're not investing
in um the western market you know uh or
the eastern market i think one of the
ways that they possibly could do that
would be a square enix acquisition
because remember that was wrong a little
while ago with microsoft buying
everything what's up it's not that
it's not that they're not investing into
that market
but they're not doing it on their own
mayor it's like their studios you know
what i'm saying like
they're that you know they're getting
like the personas and stuff but
it's it's like we see right now we see
this going on with why i say you know
microsoft needs to do better in
talking with uh you know japanese market
games and making sure that the japanese
market games are doing better because to
me
you could still you can get the
the capcoms and you can get the sega
games for this instance when it comes to
microsoft but unless that market sees
you invest in your own brand they're not
going to take you as serious as you
would if you did invest your own brand
that's why i think like with so with
sony you know they shut down japan
studio like
word of mouth gets around quick there
and they're very big on tradition in
japan
well i thought they well i i knew that
they had a thing with japan studio but i
thought they had consolidated that team
to uh
sobe right for the people who made um
astro boy i thought they did that
but that's pretty much like
we're we're going to relocate these jobs
like this
it's like we got talent there we're
going to really cut the jobs i don't
necessarily think that's like
like that doesn't make it look better
it's like that's like okay you know we
got all this talent let's just merge
these two studios together but we're
taking away
the the creative freedom of japan sony
uh sony japan because at that point
they're not they're not sony japan
anymore they're a completely new studio
so the heads of that new studio is going
to have the reigns not the heads of
japan studio
i got you i follow i'll follow yeah
that's
that's a very telling thing um
yeah and that was europe by the way so
thank you chad for that thank you for
correcting me on that i thought it was i
just didn't want to assume
that to me is very telling also with the
europe stuff um because what's up i
think the biggest issue is just like we
need
i think
we need to actually see it official but
do you find this surprising like on the
rail do you find this surprising
yeah if it's true if it's true for sure
because i don't i couldn't remember the
last time microsoft was that close to
playstation in terms of like sales
numbers i couldn't remember because we
just saw something
well we just like had official numbers
come out of whether it was a few months
ago i think
playstation was at 10 million
and xbox was at 6 million
so we we just saw numbers like that so
and i'm not saying that the tithe is
shifting
but i mean this is a good start i mean
you know you got a lot of great xbox
titles that's coming going straight to
game pace that will sell you an xbox
series that's that will get you you know
one of those serious consoles man
regardless if the game's on pc and that
they still got you know halo comes out
what tomorrow right
[Music]
i mean forza is already there i mean the
incentives there i don't know if the set
is um
an exclusive however doesn't really
matter i mean you know 12 minutes a lot
of people don't know 12 minutes is on
playstation as well but you can play it
for free through via game well free via
gamepad so they they had like a little
run since july about them just releasing
different titles they got a gaming yeah
contending synchronized too so
it
i i guess maybe it wouldn't surprise me
at all but um i think that's if this is
true i think that surprise drop with
halo help because you remember we was
just you know just reacting to the show
and everything
and then out of nowhere at the end of
the show oh the hello multiplayer is
live and everybody
whether you're a playstation fan xbox
fan nintendo fan everybody seems to be
enjoying enjoying halo infinite and
we'll get to the the reviews a little
bit later um yeah i gotta ask some
questions for you in regards to that but
no i guess i don't think this would be
surprising
so question to you about
do you think that maybe
the
bethesda acquisition is like helping
them with these sales too on top of
everything else because you see news
popping out on uh
on star field you know they had a couple
trailers pop pop-ups in the past couple
weeks uh there was that news that was
rolling around that uh they finally
officially confirming that elder scrolls
online elder scrolls six is a pl is an
xbox and pc exclusive do you think that
might have anything to do with it too
a one thousand percent i actually can't
believe that i actually forgot to
mention that yeah the um
all of that helps but with the other
scrolls thing especially because a lot
of people were wondering because elder
scrolls technically would be considered
a legacy title but apparently elder
scrolls six ain't so
you know what with these little it's
like you just chipping away at a little
bit you just you got this one thing here
we got this other thing here we got this
bethesda thing here we got we got
everything over here and just slowly but
surely man people are just turning the
tide if you want to play elder scrolls
and i keep trying i tell a lot of people
a lot of people not gonna build a two
thousand dollar pc to play all the
scrolls
you might have a few of those and you
don't got better two do that enough
please a lot of people ain't gonna build
a pc to play that a lot of people ain't
gonna build a pc to play halo but they
can get something for three hundred
dollars that's gonna like
put you right in the conversation just
so you can play the game with your
friends so this is this is dope man if
it's true of course if it's true
yeah and i think you know what people
aren't seeing is people
let me get this super chat real quick
before i forget so we got a two dollar
super chat from joe mack
all hell the iop lord addict and lord
hustle and motivate i appreciate uh the
love support you guys give uh so here's
what i think i think that we are gonna
see more of this um
i think you got a lot of people that's
used to how last generation was
and i don't think people really
have stepped back and really
took in
the environment that we're in now
we're not in an environment that we was
last generation because microsoft
actually has
ip to
use
sony this time they it's not like it
used to be where
sony would just have so much good
publicity constantly and microsoft
wouldn't really have that many they
would have a game every now and then but
for the most part it wasn't a lot of
good publicity
but now
it's it's arguably hostile for the past
year that microsoft has had an
overwhelming positivity and sony is the
one that is getting bad publicity
uh bad publicity but
really good games um speaking of bad
publicity i really don't want to mention
it here but it's only if you know you
know sony uh sony uh vice president
former vice president executive uh
pretty much had a little running i won't
speak on it on here because i won't
speak on my own channel just dealing
with something that is
something that will get you all the way
out the pain if it's if that is indeed
true
yeah let me speak on that real quick
we won't go into exactly what happened
but anyone using that for fan console
war stuff like come on man yeah chill
yeah
that exceeds this console or stuff and
you shouldn't be trying to use that for
your console war
battles that's on twitter but you know
i think sony's gonna be fine
but these dry spells is hurting them
you know like and i don't think the dry
spells
like right now
they're bad
but right now the only games we really
know about is god of war which is coming
out next year i think it's coming out in
2023 i don't think it's coming out next
year it'll be next year but go ahead
horizon forbidden west is which is
coming out next year
uh then we got uh gran turismo which is
coming out next year in march
and then that's all
that's all we really know like if you
look at it
naughty dog already went so they're not
going to be ready for a while
uh probably at least 20 25 before we can
see their game spider-man's in 2023 that
might get pushed back because of kovid
stop you already stop you um
january january 28th as a matter of fact
uh the lost legacy of thieves and i
think i messed that name up but that
doesn't matter uncharted 4 and uncharted
law's legacy will be dropping with
playstation fans
next year at the end the matter of fact
next month at the uh on the 28th and
then it'll be it'll be on a pc later
release something today
i mean my thing is do they have enough i
don't
i think with horizon i got the uh
special edition pre-ordered like the 20
dollar joint
i think that's enough for me
as far as playstation goes but like my
playstation has been off it's really
been oh i haven't been playing it so
i don't know man
you you said dry spells like yeah i
thought about it like i think god of war
is going to come out in like september
pro more than likely if it doesn't come
out in the like the summer time but you
probably won't it'd probably be their
big fall title
yeah see that's that's what i'm
i but here's the thing hustle like what
if they release games in the fall like
that they rarely do that if they ever
yeah
i know
that's what i'm on that i'm like
why do people think that they're just
going to because right now normally i
feel like that game if god of war was
coming out
around the summer or you know the
beginning of next year
i feel like we would have a release date
by now
because they're not the kind of people
to
you know release at the last minute uh
right now we have horizon coming out in
february like you mentioned we have gran
turismo coming out
and to me
i'm just like
if these games were coming out next year
if this game was coming out next year
why we got a release date it's exactly
what i said last year about horizon
forbidden west this it was around the
exact same amount of time the year
before that so that would have been 2019
and people were saying oh forbidden west
is coming out next year it's coming out
the holiday of next year and you can i'm
on iop saying i don't think this game's
coming out next year because we don't
have a release date yet and sony is not
the type of studio and not the type of
company to
randomly launch games so i feel like
what's going to end up happening is
they're going to wait next year and then
they're going to announce it's been
pushed back to 2023. now people keep
saying oh addict why would they announce
the game came out
and then delayed twice i think that they
needed something lit for that for the uh
the uh whatever that
certain what what when did that get
announced i can't remember exactly when
that got announced it was i think it was
that they led not their last big special
but it was that like the i made the
thumbnail for it it was the thing that i
was with y'all with um
when we did the when we did the live
reaction which the show escapes me at
the moment but it was like a playstation
thing addict i'm gonna push back on you
on that too
um oh
i'm not even talking about i'm talking
about when they just saw the jpeg on god
of war
um
i think that was 2019
wasn't it it might have been and i'm a
little foggy on that but i know they
showed it like they showed it early and
a lot of people thought it was coming
out in 2021 shout out to tony polanco
and remember people flipped out oh it's
coming out next year and i said right
there we all said it that's not coming
out next year so to me
if they were going to leverage that and
not let it come out like this year and
they knew it wasn't coming out and there
was actually uh the the actor that plays
kratos i'm sure he got hurt or something
like that and actually before that
trailer launched
he his injury was already
active so they knew that game wasn't
coming out this year they knew it was
getting delayed so they still chose to
put that information out there and i
think it was strictly to save that event
they wanted that big reveal at the end
they didn't care if they were low-key
false advertising the release date
saying it's 2021. they wanted to
generate hype going into the ps5 uh so i
here's here's my conspiracy theory
hustle yes i feel like when they did
that
they thought the game would come out in
2021 they thought it would because it
was supposed to come out last year no
it's supposed to come out this year so
they thought it would it would come out
at the beginning of 2022
you know probably around march april
they're like you know what we'll just
announce it's been delayed six months
so to me i'm thinking if the game was
supposed to come out this year
and uh the game was never supposed to
come out this year but they put that
information out there anyway because
they wanted to make that that reveal
better
what makes me think that the game's
going to come out next year when we have
no release date we've not really seen
much gameplay besides like the little
montage stuff
to me it's just like
maybe because they don't need to spend
as much time on the game because they
don't have to build the engine or
anything like that but to me it's like i
feel like this is what happened it was
pushed it was originally always supposed
to come out in 2022.
announced it in 2021 because they wanted
to generate hype now it's actually been
delayed because of covid
and that's why it's in 2023 but they
don't want to come out openly and say
that right now because they don't want
to lose holiday sales right now when
people know god of war ain't coming out
to 2023 there are some people that's
gonna be like yo i don't need to buy a
ps5 until that game comes out
so to me that has to be the case because
last year
they told us it was coming out this year
and it was there was concrete evidence
out there saying that it wasn't coming
out this year
and they did it anyway because they
wanted to generate hype for the ps5
going into the actual console generation
because people wanted to automatically
assume oh i'm going to pick up
a ps5 because god of war is coming out
next year and now i feel like they're
doing it again i'ma pick up a ps5
because god of war is coming out next
year and the next year they're going to
end up delaying that bastard to 2023.
i'm gonna keep it real with your addict
i think they announced it at the game
awards and and i would like to do a
gentleman's wager which is i don't know
25 push-ups or something who knows we'll
figure out what that is but i would do a
gentleman's wager because i've been i've
been following jeff watching what he's
doing on twitter i think they announced
the release date at the game awards
a la like microsoft did with like
hellblade but they didn't know it's like
a release date remember how they showed
it and then they showed the series x
last year
that's why i feel like that's different
because they didn't if they would have
just showed god of war would have been
fine
okay people are hype this god of war but
to me what makes this different is they
showed god a war
and then they showed that 2021 at the
end of that trailer
and then we actually have information
saying that that isn't the case and they
knew that wasn't the case when they
showed that trailer because the person
that was doing the uh the mocap for
kratos was injured and they weren't
making the game at the time
so to me
how
how can i believe them now
i mean hey things change like the
weather man i mean look i'm gonna still
hold out hope because um i'm mr
optimistic so i'm gonna hold out the
hope
i think they know something tomorrow
what's it tomorrow or third it's
thursday so i think there's something at
the game awards on thursday um y'all
make sure y'all tune in out to the lp
channel because they will be going live
i will be there in spirit of course
because that's my bedtime but um we are
doing a lot of reaction to it so i can't
i can't wait for that man
i'm gonna make sure i'm there when they
when they announce it i just want you to
look on your face when you know what i
mean
see i'll be okay with being wrong
because my ps5 has been in my brother's
room for like two months i ain't touched
so i'll be okay if i'm wrong that means
i get to put that thing on and i'll be
thrilled but right now it's not being
booted because there's nothing to play
on it that i particularly enjoy and i'm
saying that there's a lot of stuff you
could play on the playstation there is
reasons to buy the playstation it's just
people that have played those games
there's not a whole lot to do just like
for you know and i think you know let
let's let's let's circle back a little
bit let's circle back all right uh let
me get this super chat before we get
into this this
this rabbit hole i'm about to send us
down
so we got a two pound super shot from
raiden blade is it uh is it free lost
legacy just wondering no it's not that's
not that's the name of it
i will look that name up in a second but
i think it's the lost legacy of thieves
i'm i taught the name up you have to
forgive me of course but um
yeah yeah that's not the title though
hold on i'll check that up while we're
going through everything that we're
going through okay all right so
here's my thing
okay right now we're having a dry spell
for playstation we really haven't had to
drive uh anything
people talking about playstation since
you know maybe
um
what's that game the cartoon game
no the other one um
you guys know what i'm talking about i
was making fun of the trees not blown
what was that game called
back in front of the trees now blowing
what it was what the pixel art game that
just came out it's in nominations what
is that game called
chat help me out
stop making me look bad i need help
uh
uh
man i don't remember what it is i know
that chat's eventually going to tell me
i just can't remember what it is right
now
but we're going to continue
uh we really haven't had anything since
that game came out
and uh kina kina there we go
yeah oh wow
we haven't really had anything you know
maybe like a little ratchet and clang uh
desolute and i'm not saying that
they have had a bad year they haven't
had a bad year
i'm just saying that you know that
during that time when playstation was
constantly having a good steady of
amount of games coming up regardless if
it was microsoft's game death loop or it
was you know other people's games like
kinah
and then they had writing like fraternal
and then the show came out for both
platforms but it was actually on game
pass so
i feel like people
look it was a dry spell for microsoft
there's no denying that anyone that
denies that is just you know they're not
really
they're not really trying to be logical
and see it from both sides but i do feel
like game pass is a factor
that people love to try not to take
you know
thought process into so like look at it
from this standpoint
game pass is constantly releasing games
that you might not like
or you might like and they're constantly
giving you a chance
to look into a game that you actually
might really jump into there's been a
few games this year that i've been ever
played the ascent 12 minutes and then
you got the random sprinkles that they
put in game pass throughout the years
that i do feel like it gives the xbox
audience something to play during these
dry months that you would not normally
have something to play but it's not like
that on playstation when playstations
dry
playstations dry they got nothing like
that going on and i think you know we're
about to get to it but the playstation
game pass i think that's the reason that
sony is really trying to get their hands
on that market because they see that
like and what's funny is people act like
game pass
isn't something that is sustainable game
pass is something that you know
is bad for the industry but
first off game pass wasn't the first one
to do ea access kind of was
uh second off
they took that concept from ea access
and then ubisoft did it and now sony's
looking to do it so my question to you
hustle is do you think that
when it comes to game pass and we'll go
ahead and move over to the playstation
game pass do you think that that is a
key factor that playstation sees as a
weakness to their platform because when
it is dry much such as you know the
months we're going on now
it's very clear on playstation but when
there was dry months going out to the
beginning of the year that people that
actually had an xbox and had game pass
you didn't really see their fan base
saying it was so dry because they always
had games to play
yeah um and that's that's one thousand
percent um you brought it up earlier um
you know with your explanations in the
last segment
um i got a game on xbox game pass now
like you as you saw yesterday i was
playing um i was playing gears one for
the first time right that's on game pace
you need to put all the gears in there
but they you know but that's neither
handle there they got gears one four and
five over there in the dlc um the awful
escape is something i want to bring
bring to their attention if i wasn't
interested in halo i have enough to
substant excuse me subside like my
interest in anything else that'll keep
me on the xbox platform and of course
playstation sees this as a weakness
because they wouldn't even bother
implementing this and i'm gonna be real
with you if those if that rumor from
bloomberg is to even be believed which
it is because jason schreyer he
uh he typically don't miss he typically
don't miss his batting averages like 850
sorry for the sports reference for
sports reference however however
i'll say this
yet not only do they see that they need
something like that but they they've
been so that they needed something like
that and you know you said ea started
this whole thing right but microsoft is
going to be able to not only you know
pick up the way where ea started but
they're going to master what they did
and what i mean let me tell you what i
mean by that edit you mentioned it
earlier about the bethesda acquisition
about all these different acquisitions
the roman seiko acquisition there's a
lot of rumored acquisition a lot of
acquisitions you got dome you got what
death loop which is over there i think
it's a lot of stuff that's over there in
game pace like if you're not interested
in one game you and i sound like a
commercial but you will find your new
favorite game over there like i'm
playing like i guess i'm playing gears
one for the first time like i like i
love gears 5 and that's what brought me
back to it but um i like the art style
in the artful escape like that game to
me looks really good especially at 4k 60
whatever whatever whatever right
to me that like that's a
keeping point then like i'll just keep
my subscription over there if i wasn't
interested in halo which i got like 30
hours in if i wasn't interested in halo
i'm playing a lot of other stuff that's
over there and it's like you know
playstation but i'm having all of those
dry months on my playstation honestly i
gotta i didn't really get into the new
ration and clank but on my playstation
i've been playing like the old uncharted
games well i've been playing you just be
real just older stuff and what's funny
is like you know uh i did have some
people asking me on um on twitter
uh because i was drinking out of this a
couple days ago
okay and people was asking me what is it
this is our little
our little cups that's on the website so
uh anyone that was asking me you know
they these are sold on that website uh
they're nice little things man i like
these man you guys should jump on these
they're nice but
what i like to see and what i see is
like those games
really help people
stay in the ecosystem and it helps have
it helps people just have something to
do
and i think that's what you know people
don't like to admit
when it comes to playstation
when they are dry they're dry the only
thing you really have is the third-party
games
and
when you have game pass and even know
that some of these games might not apply
to you
there's a good chance that microsoft is
putting stuff that does apply to you
keep at the beginning of the year when
they was dry outriders people played
that for like a month and a half to two
months
on one of those show people played the
show constantly 12 minutes sure that
wasn't a long people probably can't get
people uh you know stable for a week
maybe two
uh you know these scent i know people
playing these are still right now
so that's good these little sprinkles
keep people good now let's talk about
this playstation game pass code name
spartacus
how much of that do you know hustle
how much of it do i know
very little very little of what i saw um
and shout out to hip hop gamer a friend
of the show as far as i'm concerned cool
dude to me
he um
he had mentioned
get him on the show one day
actually i think that would be a great
idea you know here brought up something
back when the with the rumors of the
playstation 5 was coming out it was
something about the backwards
compatibility
being implemented from all the
playstations in there so i saw that this
new spartacus thing has three different
tiers first of all that's the l and i'll
tell you why that's a
if if this is if the pricing is based
off of anything that playstation now did
all playstation fans need to be in
trouble that pricing if y'all remember
was god-awful it was like 20 a month and
it was it was
the it was like 99 cent the rant it was
it was a wild
it was a wild like pace game or whatever
it was a wild charging scheme whatever
was going on over there i hope they
don't reenact that i think that they're
smart enough not to
go backwards like that so but i i know i
saw three different tears and i could
pull this up as we're talking but i saw
i saw three different tears man and
so kind of don't yes sir
why you bring that up
i'm just cause we just went over this on
iop i'm bringing this up out of memory
the first tier
is playstation plus correct
then the second tier is playing
playstation four and five games
and then the third tier is placed is
playing playstation one
two and three games i don't know maybe
not three it seemed like they were kind
of focusing more on the streaming
service platform of that but to me
that that just doesn't seem right hustle
like
something about that
just sits with me wrong
well attic you remember in the
playstation 3 they had to sell
architecture if that is hard harder to
bring the other games over
then i can see why i set up that way but
honestly like that the whole three tier
thing it doesn't have to be that nah
just let me play all the games that i
want to play
for at least if you're gonna put it on p
the bro yo literally they can literally
copy game pass the blueprint is right
there you can either put ten dollars on
pc or you can put was this playstation
whatever the playstation
equivalent to ultimate is you just put
all of that stuff for one low price even
if it is 20 you get all of the games
from all five consoles because they said
some new stuff was going to be there too
i don't know if you saw that at it but
they did say some playstation 5 stuff
was going to be there too now when i saw
that i was i figured you know figured
maybe they went like the ps now stuff
like golf followers on ps9 if you
haven't played that um
you know i'm a pass on that one but
godfather's over there and whatever i
think abe
what's the abe's odyssey
the the newest apes the newest r world
is over in playstation plus two so it'll
probably be one of those type of things
but
honestly if i'm if i'm playstation i
make it either one set price on pc like
microsoft does or i just give an
ultimate version for maybe five even ten
dollars more even like they i feel like
i feel like playstation get away with
that because they i thought i said they
thought i heard that that would have
veto titles as well
yeah vida i think it was psp i think i
was correct or not psg i don't know but
okay
i feel like
okay here's what i said on iop
i don't understand why people think this
is going to work
hustle
right now on playstation now can you
play ps4
in ps5 games in the future because
that's they're bringing those into the
game into the platform eventually uh i
would assume that this wasn't happening
that would just naturally follow the
order where you would see games like
demon souls eventually come to
playstation now after a certain amount
of time uh can you play those games on
playstation now
um playstation now i'm not sure download
them on playstation
oh you can't okay i didn't know i had no
idea i have a reasoning for these
questions oh it's a replacement okay
in playstation now can you stream games
yes yes now that i do know so
to me
you're already paying for that service
it's 9.99 a month
so what are they doing by adding it to
playstation plus and tier system when
you already have access to that service
right now and it's not successful
like to me
why is it that they're splitting
playstation now into two different uh
tiers one is going to be for the ps4 and
ps5 tier two and one's gonna be for the
streaming services ps1 ps2 and ps3 for
the third tier does that make any sense
to you
no but none of it does um i'm just gonna
be real with you like the whole
splitting it up i mean i
i look if you're gonna get the money get
the money i get it i get that
i just i look you could they could
easily just follow microsoft on what
they did they could easily just follow
because like the blueprint was right
there like you saw what is successful
and a lot of people say oh game pace
isn't successful it isn't sustainable
i i think i was listening to defining
duke and there was a gentleman who
submitted a question and he had actually
did the math on everything
look
if i find it you know i'm not going to
leak it but if i find it i'll tweet out
the actual math that this gentleman did
but it sounded like it made sense he
said as long as you have a certain
amount of people and i think he just
rounded it off everybody paying ten
dollars as opposed to the one dollar or
fifteen dollars
pretty much microsoft would make their
money back in like a few years time so
like so it's sustainable i mean i think
that with stuff like that you can see a
sustainable look playstation shouldn't
split this up in the three tiers i'm
with them getting money but like if they
are going to split it up in the 310s
they got the way to do it but
we just i don't want the pricing to be
off and i'm trying to answer your
question eddie but that pricing like
that ps now stuff like ps now scared me
when it came out like if you remember
that pricing it really scared me when it
came out so i said i'm good we go we'll
go ahead
so here's my conspiracy theory
i feel like
microsoft
is
one second
i feel like microsoft is
very successful with game pass
and i think sony sees that value that it
brings to their platform is a huge
problem to their platform
because regardless if you have the best
games and you will so right now sony
definitely has the best games
there's one thing that people value over
anything else
that is value they uh it doesn't matter
where you are in the world
people are going to value saving money
then they're going to value amazing
games sure they're going to still want
those amazing games but they value the
money that's in their wallet over those
experiences
they're all going to be able to go out
there and buy them but
once again they don't the casual runs
the market sure the hardcore
runs uh they're going to value those
experiences probably over the value of
their wallet because they because that's
what we do we waste money every year on
stuff we don't even use
but the casual is not like that the
casual is going to see that game pass to
be like
sure i'm not going to get god of war
right now sure i'm not going to get the
next uncharted the next last of us right
now but for three to five hundred
dollars in a fifteen to ten dollar
monthly thing
i have access to games every month i can
play no matter what it is and then the
diverse library that's microsoft's
coming out with i have access to a
variety of different games
doesn't matter what type of gamer i am
if i'm a racer got the four is this if
i'm a halo fan got the fps's gears got
the third person hellblade got the third
uh the third person
action adventure game
skyrim starfield got the rpgs on lock
then you got you know gears tactics and
whatever they do with that franchise
going on out got the
rts's well you know pretty much like the
turn-based thing then you got the age of
empire the actual rps
rts's and i think sony's looking at that
and was like look we're going to do well
because we have great games
but when fable drops
when
outer worlds 2 drops when eldon
the elder scrolls 6 which is going to be
a huge title drops
when starfield drops when hell blade 2
drops i might have said i'll play two
already i don't know you did but you
know but but i'm gonna throw one in
there for you when perfect dog drops
i don't care what i gotta do to get an
xbox and i got a pc but i still wanna i
wanna i'm gonna buy it on both platforms
like that's something that i'm
personally looking forward to yeah
microsoft and i didn't even think about
that game
whatever the doom successor is whatever
uh the indian jones game coalition's new
game the next year so like
to me sony's looking at this at this
this map
and they're like we're fine now
because we can take on game pass with
good games right now
because the other side
doesn't really have the caliber games
that we have and they're not close to
our caliber
but if this fable drops in his heart
we're seeing now halo infinite 86 87 all
metacritic i don't know what it is now
sure some of you might not believe them
at a creek and i don't to a point but it
is an engagement of what the industry
felt about that there's more issues with
metacritic to really take it serious but
you could still
see what the pulse is on a game through
metacritic sure you might not agree that
you might agree with it but they're like
you got that waistline 87 87 88
you know you you got death loot which
was like an 89
they're like when these games actually
start dropping
consistently
can we handle those games
and game pass together
and i think sony's looking at this and
it's like we can't
we will
and i don't think that they're thinking
they're gonna lose the uh the
the they're gonna lose the market or
anything like that i think they're
looking at it as like
we'd be stupid not to do something
proactively right now
to combat what we what the future looks
like so i think you know they got the
little room together like what can we do
right now all right playstation now is
not doing that well
so what we can do is
we can merge that with playstation plus
and make tears because we need to
rebrand playstation now anyway
and
so to me that second tier is what they
really want people to subscribe to
that's going to be the prime thing that
they're going to do is that second tier
but i do think that let's say three four
years down the line let's say
all these games start dropping and
microsoft is
hit every three months
out of the park out of the park out of
the park and then they got these indies
just sprinkling every month and i think
sony's gonna be like
let's hit the red switch and that is
going to be
that third tier that has some random
play streaming games from the ps1 ps2
ps3 that's going to be where we drop our
games day and date
is in that third tier because if you
look at it hustle why does that third
tier exist
i was going to say it look yeah it makes
no sense for that that they could
literally put that with tier two
why put that in tier three unless they
want that t and they could always add a
tear that could be a fourth year in the
future
but to me i feel like they're putting
this out there and like we're not
committing like microsoft is now because
we're doing good but if stuff goes down
the road and avow see someone brought
that up i forgot about a vow skyrim
outer worlds 2 elder scrolls not skyrim
elder scrolls 6 star field they start
coming out and they start hitting hard
every three to four months because
that's what it's looking like it's gonna
look like every three or four months
like hustle we did a show a couple
months ago talking about where these
games could be
and we was happening to
like we was deliberately saying that
they might have to delay certain things
even though they're completely done
because they don't want their game
stepping on each other too much so
my question
to you
is is it possible do you think that
playstations like let's proactively set
this service up that is stuff does start
to in bad for us and we start to lose
some of the market share because of the
value in the games that they're bringing
to that service we could drop our games
on on our own platform because we've
actually proactively throughout the past
couple years set this service up to do
just that
yeah um one thousand percent also
i don't know if you mentioned it i think
the service is coming to pc as well i
got a reason for saying that um was it
it must have been last year sometime or
maybe it was you know well it must have
been last year maybe 15 months ago
whatever
remember when uh sony had invested into
epic i think they given them like 250
million dollars and then they had turned
back around a little bit later on and
then gave him more money on top of that
so that that service is going to go to
pc as well um they need to do that they
they absolutely should
i would say follow the leader but they
are the leader they they should follow
suit in terms of what microsoft is doing
because yeah you said there's a third
said there when they don't need it there
i think that this stuff is for day and
day now a lot of people may not
or
fanboys quantum court may not like that
but that's okay like that ain't for
y'all like you can still buy them games
at 70 dollars on pc trust me and when
uncharted 5 come out i'm buying it on
ps5 and i'm going to buy a digital copy
on pc i love that series that much when
god award comes out if you like that
series that much you can still cop it
for 70 dollars but if they have an
alternative the way you can play it for
ten dollars a month dang it or say 20 a
month day and day people will do that
too
people would definitely do that too and
um they gotta strike now because yo like
addict you brought all those games up
earlier i'm not a fan of half of those
games however a half of the new stuff
that microsoft was going out coming up
with however
perfect dog for me is is the starting
point just like fable for you is that
point
i i tell you man they play playstation
they smart they got they want to get it
together they gotta get it together baby
like is that
that that's an onslaught like regardless
of if you're interested interested in
that it's literally them throwing
tomatoes at the stage or throwing egg
what's the spaghetti throwing spaghetti
at the wall until something's stick
at that point and what's funny is when
something sticks they re-think how
they're throwing the spaghetti all right
this stuck why did this stick let's
throw it different ways so we can have
more spaghetti stick and i think that's
what people people are like
addict
why would they put playstation games
when they sell so well
that is a good point but the point isn't
about
whether or not the games are selling
it's about what brings value to the
platform
and if they're losing marketplace
because the value isn't is nearly as
good as is on the competition where you
can pay a subscription service and get
all access to all these games throughout
the year on top of the third-party stuff
they do because i do think they're still
going to do third-party stuff and
they're still going to get the highest
value
indie games think about something just
as simple as hades
hades came out in game pass day and date
when it came out to the platform
it came out to playstation we gotta buy
it buy it um hustle if people own both
platforms where you think they're going
to play that at
i mean look i'm going at the very least
i'm going to try it first for the
minimum amount let me just say that
because i don't know if i won't like it
or not but i will try first for you know
whatever is going to be the free one at
like if i'm already paying for game pass
i'm already over there i see uh uh we
have a i wanna say a troll account in
the chat but hey look i'm gonna be real
with you chief
i ain't gonna say it's not looking grim
for playstation don't don't get that
twisted they still make great products
but they are going to have to adapt with
the times you know microsoft is changing
this stuff again about my almost curse
microsoft is changing this again like
they you know they implemented you know
broadband they implemented the hard
drive and the thing and they made
everybody else do that right they did
this back in 2000 so so i feel like
they're they're doing this again they're
doing this with another way to sell you
something um
my issue with gamepads and then i know
that someone had nothing to do with
nothing is that you don't actually own
the title now i know say oh well hustle
you game on pc yeah but i also buy
physical stuff for like all of the games
that i have which i'm not going to pull
out right now because i don't
i can't see none of them it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter all this just
just know all the stuff that i got
i got digital backup for it too even
with stuff like this so it's just it's
just a thing
okay look i don't wanna say playstation
in trouble
because i'm not gonna say that i'm not
gonna say that playstation is not in
trouble but they do have to make some
type of change they gotta adapt in some
type of way addict if we saw like a
bunch of other two-man shows from the
people who we got love for in the
community you know just just
insert names here right if we saw that
they were doing something that they was
extremely successful
would we not implement some of those
things that they do to be successful
if it does make sense to us and and keep
it rolling and i think
you know
it's not necessarily about
look at blockbuster i'm sure when
blockbuster was at its height they
didn't think they were going to be
touchable way they at now they done
you know and that's the point is
sony is a multi-million dollar company
they are not going to
do something
that
continue to do something when they see
the industry going a different way
they're going to adapt and if they don't
adapt they deserve to go down and sony
isn't the type of person that they're
going to go down without a fight they're
going to make sure that they're able to
go left to things go left
you know they're not going to stay on
the the middle path when clearly the
party's in the left row you know what
i'm saying it's down that road it's not
it's not in the middle and you know we
got a five dollar supercharger from uh
el nino sony will never do a day and
date release for new titles on any
streaming service they want that 70 from
you
i agree with you it's like it's like we
said earlier they do want that 70 from
you but it's like i said
if it gets to the point where the value
is so overwhelming for the platform that
is more important to them than that 70
because if no one's buying their product
then the 70s useless and i'm not saying
nobody's never going to buy their
product but i've always felt like
it's not a competition to fight gamers
hardcore audience because that's who
this applies to to fight the hardcore
audience
for for them to buy your platform most
of us buy both anyway
you fight the hardcore audience
to play their to play your platform as a
primary console as a primary gaming
platform that's what you're really
fighting for
right now a lot of people have xboxes
that primarily play on xbox that plays
playstation exclusives and then you all
have on the playstation side you got the
other way around
they want you on their platform as much
as possible because they want you
spinning on their store they getting
that 30
they want you buying their games their
services they even want you as numbers
to go to netflix and stuff and saying we
want this because this is how many
people on our service watch your on our
platform watch your service they want
you on that day don't let don't get that
[ __ ] twisted they want you in there 24 7
if they can that's why microsoft and
game pass is so
so strong because at the end of the day
it doesn't matter what you want if
people are on your platform all the time
because they see value in it and they're
only playing playstation two or three
times a year for those exclusives and
they're never touching it again who's
really winning at that point
yeah that's true um well and jim
i mean look
we can speculate about that off oh you
know back and forth all day jim ryan did
an interview that just came out maybe it
was two or three months ago whenever the
last time i was on iop uh me and king
had had a ball with that he pretty much
jim ryan said i wasn't good enough and
respectfully and i say that with all due
respect um is something in trouble no to
answer that question in the chat no but
i do want to um read um a chat from
ramon g sony will do day and date when
they feel forced all right now you're
right
they might feel forced it might be a few
years from now right
addict just went over all side of stuff
that is coming that a lot of people are
excited for if you want to you might not
be excited for all the stuff that's over
there but you're definitely excited for
some of the stuff that's coming with
fables and all the other titles that
we've mentioned that nauseam at this
point yes sir keep in mind i know i
mentioned a bunch of games
i didn't mention the next horizon i
didn't mention all the content they're
going to be sprinkling with halo i
didn't mention the next state of the
state of decay i didn't mention the next
game that the people who make star
filter making after elder scrolls i
didn't mention the next
a vow that they do
i mentioned the next title they're
making that's all we're not talking
about by the time they get through this
cycle of developers making these games
hustle would it be fair to assume that
the net the people that released first
going to be ready to drop their games
more than likely more than likely
because you know they have multiple
teams working on
they have you know they'll have like the
the people who making hell blake they're
probably working on something else to
people who are working on um
fable they got a subs they probably got
a little team off in the corner working
on something else and most uh studios
work like that that's just something
that i've come to learn fairly recently
too so yeah like safety
waistline three came out last year
by the time let's say hell blade drops
in like 2023
waistline three voice the next wasteland
or the next game they make i don't think
they're making wasteland but the next
game they make that's probably going to
be ready
and then after you start going through
that then the next outer world is going
to be ready
a
expansions are probably going to be
ready like that's their goal like people
who can't sit there and say microsoft
can't live with this type of they can't
keep funding this
i'm telling you right now multi-trillion
dollar company they're going to have an
initial investment and they're going to
see where that goes and if they see
the fruits of their labor working the
way they want that's when they double
down
they keep doubling down so they're
continuously seeing their goals now sure
you can argue addict what about this
year they said they didn't reach their
goals this year they didn't reach their
goals probably by like maybe six to
seven million subscriber units and you
got to look at it from the perspective
of people going back to work uh you got
to look at the perspective of they have
grown 30 to 40
off of nothing all of year besides the
stuff that they've invested to put in
the platform
so
how much you think it's going to
increase when when halo infinite drops
tomorrow
how much do you think it decreased when
floors or horizon dropped last month
so that
all i'm saying for you guys is
we're seeing
the growth with no games and only stuff
that they've put in the platform and i'm
not saying they had no games but you
know a set they didn't make 12 minutes
they didn't make the show they didn't
make outrighters they didn't make that's
money they invested to keep you in that
platform so when their games are ready
imagine when the vow comes out and you
could just pay that money and get into
it imagine when starfill comes out next
holiday and you could just pay that
money and get into it that's what
they're what they they are
waiting for when they're getting their
studios uh
what right now we saw on netflix you
know how many friends i know that
haven't had netflix in like six months
to a year and then when squid games come
out uh hustle guess what they did
and they they got netflix again
that's that's the point you got to keep
these people into the ecosystem so
let's go to the main event hustle let's
go all right
so you said you got questions for me uh
go ahead and ask them now the chat
you can ask me whatever you guys want
it's probably best if you super chat uh
even if you super chat i'm not answering
questions i can't answer just a few
super chat let's be real here i'll
answer what i can answer
and when i can't i'll still read the
chat and i'll answer maybe one or two a
couple uh dawn super chats because i do
want the chat to be in this a little bit
because i know uh you know i have played
throughout the whole story but i will
answer what i can and what i can't i
apologize so answer your questions and
answer your question ask your question
alrighty ladies and gentlemen as we you
know we break up direct this whole thing
down we are talking about the halo
infinite
campaign i almost said multiplayer the
halo infinite campaign which drops
tomorrow so if you do have game pass i
mean you know ten dollars for me on pc
i'll be scooting that up tomorrow and
i'm gonna live stream that attic my
first question my first question sir
where are you live streaming that
i'm live stream now on the hustle and
motivate youtube and twitch channel so
wherever you wanna go y'all on youtube
so i just want y'all to pop over to my
channel i think my channel description
is in the description and all that good
stuff but wait a minute attic thank you
for that
let's talk about sound design you know
one of the most things one of the most
iconic things about halo
is the music
i'm not gonna do it i'm not gonna do it
because you're not gonna mean me however
how's the music
it's good the first question is sir the
music's good uh you know it feels nice
when you grapple hook someone you know
the uh
the banish will just run at you like you
could hear the grunts like the bandits
do
you know when you hit something it makes
it really feel like you hit and i'm not
a gun dude uh by any means whatsoever
but i've been told by a couple people
that the guns even sound good from the
multiplayer so you know they they really
hit the park out of that i don't think
they you know
obviously there's probably improvements
they can make but as far as what i
played it was it was it was a solid
experience
okay okay so i want to slow it down a
little bit i do want to talk about the
first say hour not necessarily story
related um
but you know how some games
um oh i don't know if this is a spoiler
now grand theft auto as you know if you
play grand theft auto 5 if y'all play
grand theft auto 5 y'all know it pretty
much opened up with a bang you rob a
bank off the rip um
can
you say without spoiling or maybe you do
spoil it that doesn't mean it's a bad
thing
does grand theft auto 5 oh excuse me
does hello infinite start out with the
bang like grand theft auto 5 yes
um yes and um i think you guys really
appreciate it especially the opening cut
scene um i think you guys will really
enjoy that uh i'm actually not allowed
to talk about the opening cut scene
gotcha gotcha
no no no it's fine uh but it is it's
it's a solid experience and
the main things i'm not allowed to talk
about is just story related stuff
because obviously microsoft wants the
chat they they want the chat they want
all the gamers they want you to
experience this stuff for themselves
that's why
any studio or any publisher puts a lot
of embargoes related to the actual game
in terms of story because they don't
want they don't want the story room i
mean look what's happened on twitter
people spoiling halo like crazy on
twitter oh i'm saying off of there there
we still we stay off that we off there
um glad you said that
uh
i saw it i saw your review i saw
randolph thor's review i saw i saw a
friend of the show i saw another
girlfriend at the show acg's review so i
listened to kind of listen to
everybody's
i'm just i'm gonna be honest with you
i'm happy that there's like a common
like consensus like this game
is good
like really good and probably the best
story that 343 has told
a lot of people and you know what's good
right because a lot of people are making
direct comparisons to the og uh dusty og
to the bungie um halos that that to me
speaks volumes if if you play halo 1 and
you beat that if you play halo 2 you
play halo 3. and i i want to say halo
reach was made by um
who's hella reached made by was that 343
or was that bad bungie it was their last
game
yeah so
when you
when they're comparing it to that
especially reach reach is my favorite
one so far i'm not gonna lie like that
i've always felt like
halos
are good stories but i don't like the
gameplay and how they tell them you know
what i'm saying like because i felt like
a lot of halos is just about clear
corridor going to a room clear core
going to a room and i'm not saying
that's bad it's just i've never really
uh you know
synced with that type of gameplay
i got a follow-up question and i want to
get you in trouble so you just don't ask
it does this rival
a reach or an odst
would you would you put halo infinite
better it's better
i would go
[Music]
my campaign is
halo reach is my all-time favorite and i
would say this
to me rivals halo 2 story
okay because i always liked halo 2
because they introduced the arbiter and
halo 2. uh you got to play as the
arbiter and i really enjoyed that but i
will say that the narrative in this
is probably better than halo 2.
but
i would say that there are certain
things halo 2 did better than infinite
does
but i would say like
the narrative is better because you've
never really seen you seen in the in the
trailers you never really seen the unsc
this
backed you know what i'm saying like
because sure
even at their worst they were still
better than they are now you know what
i'm saying
um okay okay okay um
[Music]
i don't know if i should mention that uh
can we mention the other characters
which characters
uh the weapon is one the palette is one
can we mention any questions about that
but okay so
i will tell you if i can't answer it
okay cool cool so i want to know about
the well i say the best for layers i
want to know about the pilot first right
the pilot
yeah it's a solid character now i will
say that
for people who didn't like seeing the
pilot i don't think you have to worry
about that too much because he's mainly
one of those characters that talks in
the background he's in a few cut scenes
you know what i'm saying like i don't
necessarily think like
he's the
like
in there a lot like he is in there but
it's mainly one of those things where
you just talk to him you know what i'm
saying like
but but what i like is like
they
they they try to do master chief more
vulnerable in the old halos i mean halo
4 and halo 5. but it always felt a
little forced just a little bit and here
you have that
but
it feels a little bit more natural like
incidents were happening where
something's about to go down and they're
like they they they can't handle that
and then she's like not on my watch you
know say they got to go through me
you're like
um okay okay um so now let's
you know what no no you know i'll stay
with the good guys first let's talk
about the weapon a little bit is she um
she to me right just from like the
trailers and so the challenge that i saw
just from like everything that i've seen
regarding her
she's like super endearing
i'll make a comparison she reminds me of
the girl from um is it a tnt you see
those att commercials at it you know
what i'm talking about right
yeah yeah the way i think she red head
or something like that she kind of
reminds me of her she she gives off like
a really like
charming personality in my humble
opinion um
does that stay throughout the whole
story does it fall flat yes
okay so she's a pillar in the store okay
that's good to know um now i'm gonna say
something that's gonna make a lot of
people upset i low-key like the weapon
more cortana like on the rail
okay i felt like right
i felt like
i'm not saying cortana didn't have her
her good things
but i'm saying
i enjoyed
talking to weapon and like because she's
a very like jokey person you know what
i'm saying the weapon is and cortana was
the exact opposite
so i i kind of enjoy her narrating
everything more than i did in uh cortana
um
okay okay um let's talk about uh let's
talk about the baddest right we know
about uh because you you had educated me
on some halo wars 2 stuff how the main
antagonist is who he is
i saw some different reviews and it's
kind of like up and down kind of back
and forth
so tell me about him and
is he is really a badass as he was in
halo wars 2.
atrialx
yes we're talking about i can't comment
on atriox what's up okay no comment okay
my fault my bad my bad my baby okay okay
okay all right um are there any other
antagonists that
oh i don't know that's a spoiler that
might be a spoiler
i will say this one thing
the actual person that's in all the
trailers because he is in all the
trailers so i can probably speak on him
he does good he does a good job so i
think you guys are going to enjoy him
okay okay okay um can we talk about the
open world stuff yeah yeah hit me uh
okay so when you first were
let's put it this way as you know my
favorite franchise is the uncharted
series uncharted law's legacy there's
chapter four i do believe when they put
you in the open world i feel like it was
like a badly
implemented thing i felt like it didn't
need it in my humble opinion and i love
uncharted law's legacy by the way
and halo infinite
is there oh boy have you played
uncharted lost legacy and if you haven't
i'll go further
okay
what's up uh
i do want to mention one question
someone brought up
can you talk about the spartan killer
addict
yes
i'm not going to say anything spoiler
with the spartan killer
but he's very present in this story
[Laughter]
okay all right okay okay so uh the
question about that i had about the open
world do you feel like it was forced
and do you feel like it was okay all
right so since you don't feel like it
was forced do you feel like it was
needed
and can we can we talk about that a
little bit i feel like
it was neither the type of story they
want to tell but i do feel like there's
better ways of doing it
uh for instance there's multiple
sections of the map
i kind of wish they would have did more
with that now
those of you that saw you saw like the
fov or foe
uh thing that that loads up
i'm kind of curious
on the mindset when they did that
i would have preferred it to be like
you know
and i'm first off when i talk about this
and i'm not confirming or denying
anything i'm not saying anything's in
the game i'm telling you how i would
have liked it i would have liked
uh you know because how
the open world works is
all the stuff you do in the game what
fob that is all the stuff you do in the
game it adds to that scale
so the higher that is the more
the more the unsc is present on the ring
if that makes sense to you because
you're you're fighting you're taking
back the ring so clearly if you're
clearing the ring there's more presence
of
the the unsc
got you so this is kind of like uh maybe
it's not exactly like this but there's a
game on nintendo called jackal i'm
pretty much in jacket you're in a jeep
and you would blow up the house just to
free the prisoners of war so by the
sound of it whatever you do on the open
world map
it kind of opens itself up it'll you can
do something to unlock something here
and get like let's say and i don't know
for sure but you'll get like different
different marines that will assist you
in your journey once you pretty much
free them by the sound of it if i got
enough to where
like when you go to an outpost or
something and you have something like a
warthog you get you get one of the
people getting like a giant 50 cow on
the back and then there'll be a rocket
launcher marine in the passenger seat
like
and if you don't think that that does a
lot
that helps they do help man they they do
have which i i love the system they did
i just i hate when people imply a system
like that with no meaning in game
like
i would have liked before maybe the last
mission like a giant war you know what
i'm saying
like you're trying to like fight your
way to their headquarters or something
and depending on how much you did in the
world that mission becomes easier or
harder
if you didn't do anything it's gonna be
hard like 20 on one but if you did a lot
of it and you really you know went above
and beyond to make sure that you freed
everyone and you got every base
then you would then it's you have like a
bunch of people helping you do it you
know what i'm saying
i would have liked something like that
done in the game
and uh you know if they didn't do that
let's let's let's look at far cry 5. you
know how like certain maps parts of the
map was owned by a different relative in
that weird-ass family maybe do something
like that
i i do feel like if you have an open
world game and this isn't just for halo
infinite this is everyone
do more with the territories in the open
world to make it more unique
mad max
like i like the way they did that that's
why that was so unique it's so fun you
got to make it to where the the mat
feels more alive and get in real life if
you're in a zone like that it would make
sense that certain people own certain
territories
right like a like an underboss i got you
like a yeah i got you i got you oh and i
like that idea too in fact i love that
idea like um
you may not remember but grand theft
auto san andreas kind of did this too
while it's not exactly the same here's
the comparison i'm gonna make before you
find big smoke at the very end you have
to pretty much get
you had to have grove street get over a
third of the gang territory so you had
to go to different gang territories and
pretty much get the information out you
know that that would be that would have
been dope and to implement it at the
very last mission as you mentioned like
instead of one on 20 right it you know
it's just the odds are even you know
whether they die in that but that
admission will be easier or be more
difficult hey i think you need to go
ahead and add uh whoever had three four
three at this point dawg you might have
a position over there that's that's a
dope idea i would have never thought of
that we got a two dollar super chat from
pixel bit g is it worth to play it on
legendary
pixel bit g this is the hardest halo
game i've ever played
um
you will get black very easy no there
you it's you gonna struggle on normal
oh
sir
but when you fight bosses
they're going to clap you
and like especially the dude in the
trailers i was saying like the uh the
dude that is in every marketing when you
fight him obviously i'm not going to
tell you where it is what it is he he a
problem so you guys i think you enjoy
some of these boss fights i really do uh
it is worth playing on legendary i
actually was playing on legendary for
the majority of the game and i had
because i was getting to the point where
i was coming too close to the embargo
and i was like i need to drop this down
heroic to finish the game
uh so i had to drop it to heroic to
finish the game
okay okay so wait i didn't want to ask
you that too so you can adjust the
difficulty uh mid game
and throughout the game if you need to
so that's that's good to know actually
for me personally um like i will play i
will play it on normal and i know what
i'm doing i play a lot of halo
multiplayer right um can we talk about
the grapple hook
um i think it was in your review you can
confirm or deny it or i don't know if
you can in that it's like a regenerating
thing right
yes uh okay it does have upgrade
abilities too so i don't know if like
upgrading it made it faster but it did
feel like when i upgraded it it
regenerated faster i do know if you
don't grapple anything it seemed like
the uh
the cooldown
like didn't last as long so like for
instance if i grapple with something and
i only grappled the floor on accident or
i didn't grapple like a person it felt
like it was quicker for me to reshoot
that than it would if i grappled like an
actual person you know what i'm saying
got oh so they gave you a personal
weapon so they gave you a redo if you
you know i mean you just didn't hit
nothing over here if you don't have
nothing at all you could shoot it
immediately if i got you remember
correctly
okay all right sounds good um this opens
up a lot of verticality that like we've
seen that in multiplayer even though i'm
not i'm not good enough right to like
use it in multiplayer so i kind of stay
away from that but um i think that's
going to teach me how to use it so i can
use it in multiplayer um let's see
are there any old weapon any weapons
from uh
the older games that make a return i
mean aside from like the rocket launcher
energy sort of stuff like that pretty
much all the weapons in the multitude
that's okay to be honest with you i only
really use the br what i like about this
is
sir and uh they i liked it because the
br is like really accurate now what
you can
kill
certain there's certain like vip targets
but they said that in the uh in their
story thing and when you kill them you
get their weapon and you could summon
their weapon at any time because like
they kind of like download the
cinematics or something so like i'll get
the the weapon that you get uh and i'll
get like an energy sword or something
and a br energy sword for like boss type
people and the br is just for regular
ads
um
i got you i got you i i mean let's see
let's see let's see are there any new
weapons that we should uh
notice in the campaign
i don't know if i'm allowed to talk
about that all righty all righty say
less say less die that
oh okay wait wait i think i'm out of
questions but i will search this chat to
see if you guys have any uh other
questions
so that is the reposter in the campaign
um i'm pretty sure it is but i can't
remember because i never used it but i'm
pretty sure it is like
i'm not gonna tell you how you get the
abilities but you do get pretty much all
the abilities that's in the campaign i
just don't remember if it's like
one for one everything in the
multiplayer
hey um i will i'm gonna say this to ron
r um i think you might want to try this
one out i know i know she had a halo guy
and trust me see i'm more of a gears
dude than the halo dude but i'm just
telling you i'm having a good time with
the the multiplayer i will tell you that
i wouldn't say that all right all right
let me talk to you a little bit about
the story and the narrative in general
um
newcomers can play this easy and
understand what's going on it's not one
of those games where like a kingdom
hearts 3 where every dialogue is like oh
this happened in kingdom hearts 2. this
happened in birth by sleep this happened
in kingdom hearts 1. i will say that 34
did did a good job where when you play
the story you don't need a whole lot of
knowledge to understand what's going now
sure there are some things that you're
like okay
what's that what's this what are they
talking about but it's very few things
but it's always one of those things
where it's like
so small you understand the narrative
that's going on but i would suggest for
you to actually go back and at least
watch the cut scenes to a hundred
percent sam or understand what's going
on but i don't think you actually have
to play
this game to understand fully what's
going on
that's good to know
that's good to know
i'm not answering that um
i
look there are certain things that
i don't want to answer because
even if
they are or they're not in there i don't
know if it's breaking nda even a comedy
on either one of them so
i mean the nda's up there's only a
couple ndas left and that's that that
goes up when the game comes out so
i'm looking forward to it
i kind of don't have any other questions
that i i wouldn't want to
even try to even attempt to try to pin
you in in some type of position but
i'm i'm looking forward to it it's um
hey did halo okay and eddie you correct
me if i'm wrong is your mother hello
dude to me not beat halo 1 but i don't
think i beat it on legendary
does this
well i guess you wouldn't know right you
only how many times you beat it once
yes once okay so yeah i didn't get
achievements so i plan on playing it
again
but i didn't get achievements because it
was i got you
achievements weren't supported um
well you know sometimes that happens
when you play games before they come out
it's not very often usually you get the
achievements for most games but
there are occasions where you know
there are occasions where you don't get
the achievements so i'm gonna be playing
through the story again just like the
rest of you guys
i think i think i think they're gonna
pop off a day one patch yeah i'll be
honest with you when you when you boot
it back up i think it's gone it's not
they definitely won't i know okay
nevermind say no more
say the wolf
all right um real quick what's your hype
level and everybody everybody in the
chat what's the hype level for the new
halo y'all y'all let me know oh one out
of ten
i think everyone in the chat is going to
be happy with halo infinite i really do
i think they did a fantastic job they
there are issues i have with the
narrative and it's not necessarily their
fault it's me being a huge halo lore
person and i expect everything my way
because i'm playing the game for myself
and i don't care
uh but besides that little selfish part
of me they did a fantastic job like they
really did like and i think a lot of you
are really going to enjoy it because
like i said they cater to the people
that wouldn't know a whole lot about the
halo universe
they made sure that you guys would be
able to play the game without really you
know understanding 100 what happened in
halo 5. what happened in halo wars 2.
there are going to be certain things
like the banished in general that you
might not know who the bandits are
because you didn't play halo wars 2 but
that's pretty much as far as that goes
like
and what's good is like even if you
didn't play halo wars 2
they still tell the story in such a way
that you that they explain to the band
star you know what i'm saying
got you i got you um do they still have
like those little like you know how the
grunts they have like their little
quirky moments like uh yes they're like
oh no these are okay they've
i guess like the bandits have bounties
on master chief and every now and then
when you get killed like they celebrate
what they're gonna do with their money
like
okay i
i i like little stuff like that so and
that's that's the old halo for me so
one time say say he's all alone get him
like
[Laughter]
so then that so it seems like because
you know in the older hellers they were
kind of like scared
so
one time from me but for the most part
they don't play the bandits don't play
like like when you fight some of the
like the people with like you know how
like in halo
they have more armor on like the the
captains have like a full set of armor
on like you get opportunities like that
and the crazy thing is
they don't play they're strong
they will mess you up
well i look forward to it i look forward
to it sound like the the sound design
which is the big thing for me sounds
like that's one point the music
obviously
i never gameplay from when i first saw
that game i never doubted the gameplay
anyway just it's halo you can't really
doubt that and if there's anything like
the multiplayer i'm gonna have a great
time
this this is this sounds like a super
dope thing and it sounds like
it really does sound like threefold
because i oh man i can't remember who i
was talking to but i said uh three four
three man that this was like a mega
break thing for them and i see a lot of
those reviews go up um just from like
this different people who i respect
yourself as the other youtubers who are
mentioned other uh different sites that
i mentioned too you know it's funny i
mean oh yes sir of what's better
343 or
uh bungie video
that video is gone game game like five
thousand views or four
i get there one day man i would
definitely get there one day no that's
what's up man it's like i told you guys
like you guys gonna enjoy it i really
think
does this completely correct everything
343's ever done no
i've never felt like 343 is a horrible
developer in making halo games i've
always felt like they make good halo
games not great halo games you know what
i'm saying but this is the first great
halo game they've made and you know they
heard they heard the outcry look at the
end of the day their developer
they're they're artists
and
to take your
something that you've spent a lot of
time to make because i mean it was
rumored i don't know if it's true but it
was highly rumored that after halo 5 and
the way the story went they rewrote the
entire story
to take criticism from your fans
and throw away something that you made
that you're passionate about that you
feel like is the way halo needs to go
and check yourself at the door and check
your ego and say let's do right by the
fans
hats off to them
yeah it definitely takes a
a group of uh very mature people because
you know just being an artist i know how
that is and
look a lot of times you think you put
out the best product and a lot of times
that might not be the case and for for
them to actually humble themselves on
that level like now we can
we can do better we can start this over
that does say a lot um i had a feeling
you know miss ross would get it right
and
shout out to her 343 man and uh stating
over there joseph staton over there this
this sounds like it's coming together to
be an amazing title multiplayer and
single player so it looked like they
finally got it right i do i'm happy to
hit i do got an announcement i don't
know how many people in the chat like
mess with like pax east and stuff
but the lords will be at pax east um
i'll probably get in trouble for saying
that i don't know if cognito wanted that
out there uh but we will be at pax east
uh you know we we we were very the
podcast was really built on going to
these events being present uh you know
we have a lot of videos from e3 to pax
uh so obviously because of the covid
stuff because of the pandemic we didn't
really get to do a whole lot of that but
uh you know we'll be able to safely
uh go i mean not safely we don't know
what's going to happen at pax east but
you know we'll be able to go to pax east
give you guys some coverage and all
that's because of you guys like this is
the first year
i've ever been able to go
to a pax east with like little money out
of my pocket and that's because of the
support the chat gives everything
this podcast gets everything anyone gets
go straight back into the podcast uh you
know that's where this mic came from the
the camera that that you're seeing now
like you guys
are the bloodline of this podcast and i
know you guys think that we just say
that we mean that [ __ ]
like
you guys
are
this podcast like you're the lifeblood
of it we got to fight out this tradition
from nathan lanston
with respect people have forgotten how
glitchy halo 2 was super jump etc
infinite isn't better isn't perfect but
it is easily as fun as the first three
it is this is the closest thing that 343
has ever done to the product that bungie
gave
i've always felt like
343 did an aspect better than bungie but
they never did both of them on the level
bungie for instance i think it felt like
halo 4 had
probably one of the best narratives did
the majority of the three of the bungee
products
but the multiplayer was horrible in halo
4. and i felt like halo 5 was the exact
opposite
like they did the multiplayer better
than the majority of bungie products but
the campaign was horrible so
this is the first time they've gotten on
that level with both but you know we're
gonna go ahead and load uh you know
close this up we've been doing this for
about an hour and a half uh i'm sure
uh hustle got something to do over there
a hustle
put your chat put put your channel in
that chat i want every 157 people
i want as many as you when you guys got
some little time tomorrow man go go
check out this man's stream see his his
reactions to the halo campaign because
i'm telling you this is
this goes to you too hustle record your
reactions
because there is plenty you're going to
have
okay
you know how i do so
i'm definitely here on youtube so let me
go ahead and put all of that information
there thank you for that attic i
definitely appreciate it tomorrow is
what wednesday
all right tomorrow hopefully 5 p.m
assuming that if i don't have to work no
later than 60 pm i will take a pause for
the calls on gears and run at least two
hours of halo infinite man so y'all can
just get my reactions there if you're
not subbed to me go ahead and do that 20
22 is going to be some changes some good
changes by the way but i'm finna just uh
you know
paddle to the metal i mean i'm here you
see you see me here you're gonna see me
in some other places man but man pedal
to the metal man i'm i'm gonna do what i
got to go do man just go ahead hit that
subscribe button hit the like button man
i look forward to halo infinite tomorrow
man y'all let me know what's going on
and uh let's have a good time cause i'm
lit when i stream i will tell you that
mama i'm a pretty good guy i will tell
you that much yes sir yes sir and i will
be changing um
what's next week
uh probably have one more show this year
and then we'll probably take a break
till next year
because next week is
the week after the video game awards and
i feel like that's worth leave talking
about the video game awards so next week
we'll probably have like a video game
awards uh we'll
we'll go into that but then after that
we probably won't come back till
uh because
we won't come back till probably the
fourth of january uh and i am going to
work with some people because i want to
change how everything looks a little bit
uh get some like promotion stuff in here
somewhere i don't know i don't know what
i'm doing yet i don't even know if we'd
be done on the fourth i'm just telling
you i'm working on it uh just bear with
me definitely you know tune in to hustle
tomorrow when uh he
he plays halo infinite like i said there
there is some definitely reaction moment
worthy you guys don't want to miss that
and i'll probably be streaming shinobi
again tomorrow i know i said i'd stream
it monday but
i've been i've been busy i can't help it
i've been busy but i appreciate everyone
coming through man and until next time
this gaming addict we're outta here
peace